welcome back everyone this is the last
final talk of the day again
ok so I'll pick up from where he left
off obviously and so we got down to here
specifications for control systems the
last thing I did so I'll pick up there
and I drew a little line I don't think
I'll get to that last topic but I'll say
now and maybe I'll remember again at the
end that to some extent the lecture they
give on Tuesday will use a lot of the
things that are down at that bottom end
so to some extent if you come on Tuesday
you'll see the things that I don't get
to if I don't get there ok so we have
these sort of design patterns and I now
want to go in and say yeah yeah so I've
been talking about what the pattern is
but I haven't said how do you design
this right the actual control design
part and so I want to do just a little
bit on the design of the feedback
controller and then the feed forward
controller right the two pieces and talk
about you know not in a great detail but
just you know what are those things
what's the computation going on in a
kind of traditional setting and then
again if I have time I'll talk about it
in a more discreet kind of computer
science type setting okay so 99 percent
95 percent let's say of all control
systems actually use something called
PID control proportional integral
derivative control and so I want to tell
you what it is
and and the kind of important part of it
in some sense is the integral part so
here we're in this reactive design
pattern and I've simplified it down a
little bit I've gotten rid of the
reference shaping bit right so I'm just
looking I've got a reference I've got an
output why I'm comparing the reference
to the output and subtracting them
getting an error right the speed of a
car whatever it is and then I have some
control computation that is going to
command some input there's some
disturbances that are going to get added
on and then I put it through whatever my
processes and a probably the most
classical type of controller and it
works extremely well so it's that's why
it's the most use it's something called
a three-term controller or a
proportional integral derivative
controller this was developed by
minorsky in the steering of ships in I
think early nineteen hundred's or
something like that so it kind of goes
quite a ways and it just works extremely
well and the idea is very simple
suppose that the computation that we do
for our controller is given by this
formula I'm going to take the error that
I have that's the difference between my
reference which is what I'd like to be
doing temperature in the room speed of
the car number of servers that are
online whatever it is I'm gonna take
that error I'm gonna multiply it by some
constant K the bigger the error the more
input that I'm going to apply it simple
enough but I'm going to add two other
terms so one term is the integral of the
error the idea in the integral of the
error is I say look suppose that I apply
that input and I'm still not like going
fast enough right or the room is still
too hot right like you know I had it was
10 degrees too hot in here so I turned
the air conditioning on a little bit
it's now 3 degrees too hot and it's just
stuck there right because the amount of
extra cooling I'm applying with that 3
degree error is just not cutting it well
one thing you might say is well if it
stays there for a while right that error
then push harder and that's exactly what
this term does I'm going to integrate
the error right so if this is positive
for some period of time I'm gonna get
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and I'm gonna apply more and more and
more input so that's the integral term
and then this derivative term sort of
does the opposite which is it says once
you see that you're starting to change
you might want to back off a little bit
early all right because I'm now starting
to make a difference if I've got a
system that's gonna take awhile right I
don't want to keep applying that input
right I finally started to speed up or
cool the room down or whatever so start
to back off a little bit so this three
term controller then you could think of
it as having a part that looks at the
present
that's this proportional term the
present error a part that looks at the
past that's the integral of the error
over all of the past and a part that
approximates what's happening in the
future that is what's the rate of change
of that input and I'll use that rate of
change to also try and tune what I do so
that term so I've got a present bit so
feedback is proportional to the error a
past victim in it's proportional to the
integral of the error and a future bit
now turns out actually 95% are PID
trollers probably 94% RPI controllers
that is just these two terms so this
term often doesn't get used and so I
want to talk just a little bit in words
about this term and why it's so
important so what the integral term does
is it allows you to adapt to certain
uncertainties in particular it allows
you to adapt to constant disturbances so
suppose that I'm travelling along in my
cruise controller and I go up a hill
okay and I slow down a certain amount
and then I press the gas right to speed
up but I don't speed up enough okay then
you're gonna have an error still so
you're gonna press harder and you're
gonna still have a little bit of errors
you're gonna press harder when are you
gonna stop pressing well when the error
goes to zero you're gonna stop changing
it all right so we're going to integrate
this past error and at some point this
integral is going to have some value and
that value is essentially the amount of
additional input I needed to apply to
compensate for that hill and so without
even knowing like the steepness of the
hill or anything else I essentially
figured out right
how much extra input do I have to apply
to completely exactly cancel that and if
you design this right if the system is
stable that is the error goes to zero
right
then it the only way this system can be
stable is if the error essentially goes
to zero right otherwise this thing's
going to constantly keep integrating up
or down depending on whether it's
positive or negative
right so whenever you put integral
feedback in what you're sort of
guaranteed if you design it right is
that the error will go exactly to zero
this is what your car uses right to go
to exactly 55 miles an hour you go up a
small hill right it'll push a little bit
right you go up a bigger hill right it
will integrate up and it'll push more I
mean and it will get it up to the limits
of the amount of input you can apply
right obviously big office Hill that's
so steep that my engine cannot apply
enough torque in order to go up to it
right something's not going to work
anymore and I'm going to have to slow
down
if they haven't been a big issue right
so meaning people have figured out how
to do these numerically correctly and
get rid of the noise and other things so
yeah I'd say it's it's practically solve
problem so okay so these PID controllers
turn out to be you know sort of
ubiquitous because they do lots of
things very well there in all of the
heating systems they're probably in your
battery power supplies and you know lots
of other places that they know that
you're sitting there and they're a way
to allow the system to take into account
constant disturbances or maybe your car
is heavier than it normally is you'll
compensate for that - it's all sorts of
uncertainty right that gets kind of
compensated for right with an interval
term now the derivative term just to say
a little bit about it is typically there
for systems that have long delays right
that is that I applied some input it's
starting to turn the right way and if I
don't if I the errors I still have an
error potentially all right and so I'm
still going to apply at the least this
proportional term but now until this
error goes through zero I'm going to
still apply right the same sign of the
input and sometimes you say I need to
back off more quickly than that right so
that derivative term is an anticipatory
term that says I'm going in the right
direction you use it for systems where
that you need to anticipate ahead of
time you came up in ships because ships
are very slow right so once you know
you're trying to turn and point to
something right and if you don't start
backing off on how hard you're turning
you'll overshoot right and so it's a way
to kind of keep it from overshooting so
that's why I'm minorsky Wright came up
with this three term controller okay so
how do you design these things well
essentially we need to choose the gains
there's three numbers in here right so I
give you a system I've got some model of
that system I got to do some analysis on
that model you can trivial and sort of
dumb way to do it but you can think of
it as I just going to simulate the
system a whole bunch of times
right pick different gains and find ones
that do the right things what do we want
it to do to this question that came up
earlier what's the specification well
first we want it to be stable right that
is that we want that when we put this
feedback controller in there that we
converge to a fixed speed right and not
oscillate right because we could
oscillate with this stuff I mean I could
integrate the error and I apply a bunch
of input and then I start to slow down
and then I integrate the other way you
can get oscillations quite quickly out
of this if you're not careful
I want performance so I for example
to track the reference and again I would
say something like I want you know
within five seconds to be within ten
percent of the desired value and within
twenty seconds to be within point one
percent or something like that I
probably also want the disturbances
should be attenuated remember in my
cruise control example this was the hill
right now I want the effect of the hill
right if I didn't have this controller
in there I would just hold the gas at
some level and then when I went up the
hill I'd slow down right and so I've got
some effect I'd like less effect than
that right instead of slowing down ten
miles an hour when I go up the hill I
slowed down 21 miles an hour or
something like that so we can write
those things down and finally we want it
to be robust right so there's
uncertainty in this I may not have an
exact model my controller gains may not
depending on I implement them they may
not be exactly right like if this was an
analogue circuit and the you know they
were implemented with op amps and
resistors and capacitors they might
change a little bit over time right all
of those things so I'd like that these
properties are true in the face of
disturbances so no matter what the
disturbances are what shape they are
what types of frequencies are but also
and again I've left it off but
implicitly you should think about I know
this is only a model I know that it's
not exactly right and I'd like it to
still work even when that model is
approximate and so we know how to prove
things so a PID controller and there are
lots of you know tools that allow you to
do this roughly speaking you would sort
of give it a process description and
then you would maybe play with these
gains by hand but there are also things
that you can do automatically you kind
of press the button and it goes and it
moves the system around a little bit and
then it says here the gains to use to
stabilize that system and so these are
called Auto tuning systems and they'll
do that automatically and most like
process control if you want to control
the temperature of a reactor or
something like that they'll use PID
controllers with Auto tuning and they'll
figure out what the gains are so that if
you put it on a different reactor of a
different size with different types of
materials in it and the controller just
automatically figures out how to control
it to the right temperature so that's
going to standard technology these days
all right
another type of control design is in
this second design pattern where we
might have something that looks like a
feedback design and so let's imagine we
have a process and let's suppose for
example that's written down as a linear
set of differential equations so here X
is a vector of states for your system
maybe it's an airplane and it's the
position and velocity
and attitudes and angular velocities for
example and I'm gonna assume it's linear
dynamics which an airplane wouldn't be
but would be around an equilibrium point
right if I do small perturbations I
could kind of linearize the dynamics
I've got some input that's going to
apply and then I have some output that I
measure and here what we're going to
assume is that although I care about
what the output is that might be like
the speed of the aircraft or its
position or something like that I'm
going to assume that I measure the
entire state now in reality I probably
measure this output remember I have that
observer right and so that I'll have to
observe the entire state and it turns
out there's a very nice separation
principle you can show that if I design
as if I was measuring the state right
and then I observe as if I knew what the
control input was right I can put these
two together compose them and it will
work all right and so we'll often do the
design assuming we can measure the full
state and then we'll do the observer
design assuming I know what the
controller is right and then the two of
them fit together okay so the pattern
here then is I have my reference input
that comes in at my state that comes
back this reference input is now giving
me some desired state so this K R is
like a vector that says for this
reference input here's what your desired
state should be it's a very simplified
version it only works because the system
is linear it's going to turn out that
indeed the as a function of what the
reference input is the amount of input
that you should have sorry the desired
state is going to be a linear
combination or linear function of that
reference and I'm going to subtract
essentially KX from this so that's what
it sort of looks like as a block diagram
now if it's a linear system I can
actually write down the solutions
explicitly it's a convolution equation I
can write exactly what this system does
so I can plug everything in and sort of
solve things out and if you do that if I
apply this control law then it turns out
that the dynamics have this form and
essentially what's happening it's not
too hard to see if I put in here U is
equal to R times kr minus KX right so
this particular controller then I can
just plug that in and I get this guy and
now if I just for simplicity assume for
example that this reference is zero then
you can see I have a linear system with
a minus BK times X this is that we call
it the dynamics matrix that the system
matrix is just a linear differential
equation and we know that the stability
of a linear differential equation is
determined by the eigenvalue
right of that matrix and so I can move
the eigenvalues by applying feedback I
have the natural eigenvalues of the
system that came with the a matrix but
if I look at a minus BK right I can
change those eigen values somehow you're
doing that okay so the idea here is that
we get this system that kind of in
simple form looks like a minus BK X
stability of the closed-loop system is
just asking that we find a K that makes
this stable so you could think it looks
like a matrix pencil or something right
there's a certain set of directions that
I can go and I can get eigen values for
those different directions right an
interesting question you can ask is
where can I put the eigen values right
or if I give you an a matrix there's
some natural ligand values I give you
some inputs I can apply state feedback I
can now go to all of the eigen values of
this matrix where K can be any set of
gains that I want to use I'm going to
multiply the state rate times that K
matrix and use that for the input so we
can link those eigen values to
performance but we can also ask where
can replace them and the answer is we
can place them anywhere under certain
conditions on the system dynamics so
turns out there's a test that you can do
called the reach ability test and if the
system is reachable and most systems are
reachable then in fact I can put the
eigen values anyplace I want that means
I can design the dynamics of the system
right because the dynamics of the system
are given by the eigen values right that
determines the response of the system
the time response of the system is
determined by the eigen values so indeed
if a system is reachable and we know how
to both check of a system is reachable
and design it to be reachable you can do
that it might seem a little bit odd
because for example I might have 12
states and only one input but remember
that I'm kind of getting to apply that
input vector over time right and at
different states I get different inputs
that I apply and it just turns out that
you can set arbitrarily the eigen values
of this matrix right even if this is an
N by n matrix and this is an N by 1
vector
I mean turns out you can show that you
can under certain conditions of reach
ability set that and again those
conditions are usually satisfied so how
do we actually design this for
simple system like this we essentially
the design problem is to say given a and
B find K such that the eigenvalues are
at specified locations so that's a
MATLAB command that's called the place
command all right so you give it a you
give it B you give it desired eigen
value locations it gives you the matrix
K done right so that's control design so
you can do fancier things you can say
well you know maybe I didn't want to
place the eigen values and given spots
maybe I wanted to minimize some cost
function like minimize the integral of
the error plus the integral of the cot
of the input right so I want to keep the
error small but I want to trade that off
with the size of the input that I have
to apply right so if I did a quadratic
cost on the error and I did a quadratic
cost on the inputs all right then I
could have a positive definite matrix Q
that told me that error weighting and a
positive matrix are that told me the
input weighting and if you call the lqr
command linear quadratic regulator it
will give you the gain K that minimizes
that integral so if I can convert my
problem into this form right I just have
to call a function in MATLAB or Python
and I will get the gains and this is
what we do I think always like you know
you give me a room right and I say ok
well here's the dynamics of this room I
now you know to figure out what the
state what the temperatures are sitting
up here how much to turn the heating on
right so I give you a I give you B I
give you some cost functions to say how
much does power cost how much are you
willing to tolerate the differences in
temperature right that's the Q and the R
matrix
give me the optimal controller that
minimizes that quadratic cost why
quadratic cost because that's the
problem we can solve all right you know
it's not the right one I don't know you
probably you know like it doesn't does
it really matter whether it's five
degrees or ten degrees right you know
maybe you want some you know not okay
can't solve that problem anymore
right so we can solve this problem right
so this the problem is all alright so
that's sorry what happens and they got
I'll just point out that essentially
we're designing the dynamics by choice
of feedback right I mean this is exactly
right you know I want to design it to
minimize this cost function I want to
design it to have these close to the
eigenvalues you know give me the
feedback controller that does that okay
so for feedback those are the two
primary
techniques that we use to start with PID
control with the integral being very
important or state feedback often using
linear quadratic regulator Theory
sometimes using pole placement was
called pole placement or eigenvalue
placement as i mentioned the the student
came to me you know that's only part of
the problem and increasingly that's the
simple part of the problem that you got
to do right but it's not the part that
gives you really good performance the
part that gives you really good
performance is the feed-forward part the
planning part right that sort of
front-end so how do we solve that
problem and so let's talk a little bit
go sorry yeah sorry i shouldn't i said i
would stop anything okay so let me stop
on the feedback I did PID and I did
state space left a plane right or if
it's discrete time inside the unit
circle right yeah so typically you know
what'll happen is that you would say
well I want my system to respond fast so
the speed at response is determined by
the eigenvalues so you might want to put
your eigenvalues out pretty far to the
left right because if you have any eigen
values that are very close right you're
gonna get in the solution of a linear
differential equation you're going to
get terms that are e to the lambda times
T where lambda is an eigenvalue if that
has negative real part so it's stable
but small negative it means the rate of
convergence to zero could be very slow
so you put them out so why not put them
way out to the left well you can do that
but you'll get very large gains all
right because now right when you want to
move those eigenvalues very far away the
K matrix gonna be very large what does
that mean it means if I have a very
small error between the actual state and
the desired state I'm gonna apply a huge
input right that might be okay but if I
had noise for example in my state
estimate that gets amplified to all
right so there's a fundamental trade-off
that we understand which is that you
need to and it's the reason that people
don't do I again value placement so
often because that trade-off is hidden
right it's in there I can pick the
eigenvalues and then tell you how bad it
was and they say oh that's not very good
let me pick a new one the linear
quadratic regulator lets me specify that
explicitly I can tell you what's the
trade-off between error and input that
you want and the the linear quadratic
Gaussian problem LQG allows me to
also estimate the effects of noise and
disturbances in a stochastic setting and
so we can put that in there as well but
other questions on PID or state feedback
a complete description of the process
behavior already anyway you could
assuming that there's no uncertainty
right so again are you putting the
feedback in there to compensate for the
uncertainty the eigenvalues if I have
some uncertain dynamic so that a matrix
isn't quite the a matrix right in fact I
could have an a matrix that went between
stable and unstable but a minus BK might
always be stable for example right yeah
good question
okay so now let's talk about the
feed-forward part of this problem okay
so now I want to talk about that
trajectory generation block and again
remember that the setting is set up for
this was that I've got some reference
that's describing my task that I want to
do and I now want to compute out a set
of states and an input that achieve that
task and so a way to think about that is
that I'd like to find an input u such
that I minimize some cost function so
say some integral cost function over
some finite period T subject to the
input in the state's satisfying the
dynamics of my system so I want to find
an actual solution to my dynamical
system so this is the model for this
process P and is x dot equals f of X U
and I also may have some constraints on
the states or the inputs my input can
only get so big all right for example
and so the problem that we want to solve
is perhaps I mean it's a standard one
minimize some metric right and a typical
one would be the integral over time or
interval over space right if you wanted
to do something spatial you could do
that as well and we'll usually put in
that we want to do it over a finite time
sometimes you can do infinite time but
often finite time and then we'll put a
terminal cost so like I want to get you
know close to the Oakland Airport but
just plan out for the next five miles
right and then you know at the end of
that be closer you know if I it's better
if I'm closer than if I'm far away right
so and I'll just lump all of that into
this terminal cost B and so that is just
a constraint optimization problem like
the ones we saw all yesterday right I
mean just solving right you know sort of
constrained optimization problems and so
we can do those sorts of constrained
optimization problems and the trick is
that we need to do this at least as I've
shown it here I'm just doing it every
time the reference changes right so the
reference changes that you say you want
to go faster compute out a new
trajectory you want to go slower compute
on your trajectory remember that
eventually I'm going to do this over and
over and over again I haven't gotten
there yet but we do want to do it fast
and so there are a lot of tricks to get
very fast solutions and so I won't go
through all of those but just to say
that and I showed you what
eighteen years ago we were computing
these things out actually at a hundred
Hertz so we would calculate out what to
do for the next ten seconds every
hundredth of a second right on something
with about nine degrees of freedom and a
you know relative and the you know cost
us $30,000 at the time do it on your
iPhone today right so again the reason
these techniques are working is because
computing right Moore's law all of that
stuff is just getting to where we can
solve these things you can encode the
whole thing in various types of neural
networks and other things if you want as
I already mentioned we need update the
solutions at the rate at which the
reference is modified in this kind of a
scheme and the other thing is that we
can take into account over here a couple
of things that are harder to take into
account over here so the feedback
control designs that I showed you I
further say the state space one I gave
you a linear model but if you have
global nonlinear input saturation state
space constraints actually what you want
to do is take those into account on the
trajectory generation side of the world
and then what I'm really trying to do is
I'm trying to regulate the state of the
system to be near XD and if that's small
that is I had a pretty good model of the
system and the disturbances don't take
me too far away from where I expect to
be then I can linearize the dynamics
right around XD and i won't get very far
away from it it's like if the controller
is doing a good job it'll keep you near
the thing that if that that allows you
to make the assumption that you use the
linear model right it's one of these
circular arguments right I'm going to
use a linear model to design a
controller that controller is a good
controller it will keep me near the
place where the linear model is valid
that I use to assume I could design the
controller in the first place and that
works ok so that's what everybody does
so if you look at an aircraft flight
controller this is you know what it's
doing it's generating is Jerry to come
down and land like the auto land system
and then it's regulating around there
it's got to stay in the center the
runway you got to come down at the right
flight angle all of that stuff and it's
doing these sorts of calculations on the
inside and so you know for example you
might say well you know this ducted fan
that I showed you a little flight
control experiment you might want to go
from this position to this position you
that's a person standing there let's say
this is the roof right so I need to get
from here to here right so I can eed to
go from point A to point B in T seconds
right while staying away from these
obstacles or something like that that
would be the typical problem you solve
and again I have to use a model here
right because I've got a model of the
dynamics that model may not be right
that's okay because I'm going to put
speed back in here as well to compensate
for that right so if the model is not
quite right then this input won't quite
do the right thing right it wasn't quite
the right dynamics in my calculation
I'll be off by a little bit when I'm off
by a little bit I'll see that I'm off by
a little bit I'll correct for that right
and so it all kind of works okay so this
use of the feedback in it we often call
this the inner loop right because
there's an inner loop is used to track
it and and that corrects for
disturbances in model uncertainty so the
way we normally think about it is that
you use the trajectory generation to
handle these sorts of things global
non-linear input saturation state space
constraints that are hard to deal with
here and then you do what you can here
which is to deal with the disturbances
and the dynamics and the unmodeled
dynamics and this is often called two
degree of freedom design because you
have a kind of design degree of freedom
here what cost functions do you use and
other things as well as a design degree
of freedom here the cost function you
use for this may not be the same as the
cost function you use for this depends
you can it's you can decide they're the
same or you can decide they're different
now the other thing is I've already
alluded to that's quite nice is as I've
sort of done it here I get a reference I
can do a computation and then it's all
feedback but in fact what we do in
practice is we take the same kind of
design pattern and we wrap this outer
loop around it and this outer loop looks
at where did we actually get and then we
recompute the trajectory from where we
actually go and so the computation that
we typically implement looks something
like this I'm going to calculate out
that same integral over the time period
t from now to capital T and then I'm
going to apply the input for time delta
T so think of capital T is 10 seconds
and think of delta T as a tenth of a
second okay so I'm going to calculate
here's what to do for the next ten
seconds do that for a tenth of a second
then recompute - what to do for the next
ten seconds so this is called a receding
horizon control because I keep receding
on the horizon or sometimes model
predictive control because I use my
model to predict what to do so you'll
hear these T terms used interchangeably
model predictive control are receding
horizon control and kind of the way it
looks is something like this so if I
forget
the feedback controller for a second
we're not going to really do it this way
but pretend and then the calculation
might look something like this so you're
looking at the state a one-dimensional
state for simplicity you're looking at
time here and what I'm going to do is I
say I know I'm at this state right now
and I'm going to compute out for the
next capital T seconds this curve right
this red curve so this is the
calculation that minimizes this cost
function from this initial state and
then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to apply this input the input that
corresponds to this state I'm gonna
apply for the first delta T seconds now
of course the model might be wrong there
disturbances that I didn't take into
account right there's no disturbances in
here because I don't know what the
disturbances are right so I might not
actually end up where I thought maybe I
end up up here instead so I have some
error what am I gonna do well I know
where I'm at so recalculate from there
so now I recalculate this next
trajectory out for capital T seconds
starting from wearing that and then I
apply it for delta T seconds and then I
see where I end up and then I keep doing
this right so the curve you actually
follow right might be this blue curve
right as I do this and it's again it's a
feedback mechanism right I'm just
calculating out right how do I do this
so that idea is called receding horizon
control it's another way of doing a
feedback loop around the inner loop here
I've sort of described it as if we don't
use this at all we usually do that is we
use both loops but you don't have to
depending on things now one thing I'll
say about this is that you do have to be
careful about the terminal constraints
and the reason is because you're
minimizing over some fixed horizon and
you have to be careful that your
optimization over that let's call it
short term horizon takes into account
what happens after that somehow because
I could make the right short term
decisions but ignore right you know sort
of the implications longer on so if you
don't put any terminal cost here it's
like I don't care what happens after
that just minimize over the next 10
seconds and if that means that 10.2
seconds from now you're in front of a
wall all right I'll worry about that
later or any like 0.2 seconds from now
all right
no or kemple intersection there all
right that's not a good idea right so
you want to do something that says look
you know by the way you should end up at
a reasonable state as well so their
mathematical conditions on what this
to satisfy in order to make sure that
this whole thing is stable and works
correctly and converges and does all the
right stuff and that's a very well
understood theory and as I already said
so 95% is PID five four point nine nine
percent is this all right what's left
all right and all the fancy stuff is
this so I showed you this video already
but I'll just replay it this is receding
rise and control running it's actually
not even running the inner loop we can
calculate so fast that we don't even
need the inner loop so we're just
calculating out for the next ten seconds
what to do we do there eight hundredths
of a second we apply it for 0.1 second
so we recalculate there's constraints
there's actually a guy sitting down here
and so we're missing him every time
right there's constraints on the top of
the bottom there actuator constraints
right all this stuff works great right
and so you know very robust right very
high performance right for this type of
system this is what you know fire
aircraft use and all sorts of very you
know high-end systems but it's also what
this system uses because we're
calculating out for the next 10 to 50
meters depending on how fast we're going
what to do and recalculating
recalculating recalculating
recalculating and in implementing now
there's other higher level stuff going
on but the trajectory generation part of
this is saying well go down the road for
as far as you can see and here's the
trajectory to follow but every time I
see a little bit more Road I calculate
out what to do next and if I don't quite
follow the road I also take that into
account right so I'm just constantly
recalculating this thing again at about
a hundred Hertz for this particular
system actually it's between 10 and 100
Hertz depending on how complicated the
obstacle set is and how long it takes
the optimization to perform and other
things so that's what's being done and
this is what more or less every
autonomous car is doing right is some
version of this right you might do the
trajectory calculation on a graph you
might do it with some sort of convex
optimization you know everybody's got
their own tricks but you're just redoing
that calculation over and over again and
doing or seeding rise of control okay so
so that is sort of the the trajectory
generation first you want to just
generate those trajectories but really
it's become the the pattern has been to
wrap this receding rise and control loop
around everything at this point for most
of the things that we look at I should
say I guess you know when you do
sometimes they don't so if you're doing
scheduling for example suppose you want
to suppose you've got a bunch of
chillers up on the roof of this building
right you might say well I'm going to
schedule when those chillers are going
to
but then I'm gonna modulate the load on
the chiller so there's which chillers
turn on how many I turn on I might do
that once a day all right so I just say
hey you know it's a Wednesday it's gonna
rain so I'm gonna just calculate how I'm
going to turn that chiller on into a
clock and then I'll turn this other one
on at 4 o'clock sometimes that's a
open-loop once-a-day calculation right
because it might be easier to do or your
software doesn't handle it or you don't
want to start and turn on and off
chillers and things like that okay
questions on the kind of feed-forward
part of all this is I said a lot of the
performance you see in modern systems is
because they're making use of more
computation and doing these for Pedro
recalculations
okay so last topic then is I want to
talk a little bit about layering and
sort of how all of this stuff comes
together and so I want to do that by
sort of talking about how we do a
control design on a typical system and
then some of the you know tweaks on that
or additional challenges alright so got
some physical system that I want to
control pick your favorite application
this might be the heater in this room it
might be your car it might be all of the
routers on the Internet it might be the
planet if you wanted to do engineering
right you know you picked great your
Segway right you know anything that is
some physical process that's got
feedback around it which is pretty much
it now I've got some external
environment that that interacts with
this is the source of my disturbances
right you know remember there's
unmodeled dynamics sometimes we sort of
think of that as the external
environment right and we kind of lump it
there but I've got that there now the
very first thing that we typically do
when we're doing we designs we build a
model of both the system and the
environment and we use that model to
redesign the system I've got to decide
how big a chiller did I put on top of
this building I've got to decide that
before I actually start controlling the
chiller right so I've got to make some
estimates of what the loads on the
building are to be and how you know big
classroom do I have and what's the heat
capacity on stuff it's a car you know
how fast do I need to turn the steering
wheel of is an airplane how big a
control actuator so I need so you do all
of that and you might iterate on the
design right you might go through and
say well you know what I actually need
to reiterate my design and put you know
faster actuators different
configurations right so you do the
standard sort of a thing and then once
you've got a design you like then you
might say okay good so now I want to
make sure that at my lowest level I can
get good control properties I can follow
that trajectory right given the
trajectory and so we would do the lowest
level controller where we would say well
I've got to decide what sensors I'm
going to put on here's my observer
probably a Kalman filter at this stage
I've got some actuators that I need to
put in there and I've got some sort of a
feedback controller probably a PID loop
at this inner level and as I do this
right I might find out that I need to
redesign this actually you know when I
go and I look at the response time it
turns out that although I can hold the
temperature in a good level it takes me
three hours to get the temperature in
this lecture hall to the right
temperature when a bunch of people walk
in that's too slow so I'm gonna go
redesign - I didn't see that until I
actually went and maybe you know tried
to design the control loop and with
Unser's I've God and other things right
so you might do more design iterations
right so you might iterate on this
update the model update the system
design update the control or right go
through them then finally get a way to
say okay good I think I can hold the
temperature in this room I think it can
hold the velocity of the car I think I
can maintain you know whatever variables
that I want to maintain in some system
I'm controlling and then you might go up
to the next layer of the designs okay
good
so now I want to start moving this thing
around right now I want to ramp up the
temperature in the morning and get it to
the right temperature and so now I'm
going to do online optimization that's
the feed-forward part of this loop and I
might do more complicated things on the
state estimation side as well for
example I might like a deep neural
network that predicts what the loading
on the building is going to be based on
past patterns right so that I know that
ahead of time right because it's kind of
hard to figure out there you go exactly
how many people were in the lecture hall
you know how many different programs are
going on what day of the week is it
right all that stuff so you might move
moving horizon estimation that's kind of
the opposite of receiving rise and
control look back over time and estimate
where things are you might use deep
neural networks and classifiers and
other things you pick but this is a
higher level of reasoning going on and
then of course I might do you know
additional design iterations right oh
you know in fact right I need to change
something and then finally usually
multiple layers but you get up to the
kind of discrete decision-making layer
where you have to make discrete
decisions those discrete decisions could
be about discrete choices you make when
do I turn certain things on or off they
could be about mode and contingency
management what am I going to do if I
get a flat tire while I'm landing
that's a discrete thing that occurred
all of us are my landing gear don't go
down right or something like that if
it's a plane with a pilot you're gonna I
guess land in the Hudson or something
like that right if it's an autonomous
plane and the autonomous one has to said
what to do so we have these kind of
layers of abstraction that are somewhat
natural across you know many of the
types of systems we design now the
environment you know I sort of Drew it
as affecting things down here here's the
noise coming up here's the disturbances
I might you know have a feedback
interaction with the environment in
reality of course the environment and I
didn't come out bringing well
so it should be shaded there so the
environment in fact affects all of the
layers of the design and so you have
some representation of that now the
other thing that happens these days is
we have a lot of networking
communications that connect all of these
things together and that also kind of
feeds all the way across this system and
so all of this is part of the big
network system and what that is done is
to say jeez I can have lots of computing
available to me and and so maybe in fact
what I should do is instead of just
having a fixed system model right maybe
I should have an online system model and
I can recompute all of these things
right based on my actual model at the
time so I'm in my car and I have a
failure of the tire I got a front tire
that's flat I can say great I can
recalculate the dynamics out and I can
resolve my trajectory optimization
problem with a tire that's flat right
and actually calculate how to do that
without having something bad happen so
people are now moving to online models
and use and recomputing it's like I'm
doing the system design every tenth of a
second right now instead of designing it
ahead of time than then implementing it
right I'm actually just recomputing all
the time right so it's like I'm doing
the system design online so we might do
something like that
the other thing that you tend to find
yourself doing is rather than having one
optimization run or one decision-making
algorithm run you end up getting lots of
these all right because you say you know
driving in a parking lot is different
than driving on a highway is different
than driving in an intersection so I'll
have different things that are running
and sometimes I can't tell right I want
to dry I want to have an algorithm
running for the case where somebody cuts
in front of me but I want to have
another algorithm that's calculating out
what to do if that doesn't happen right
so you start getting lots of things
running all at the same time for
different consider the patterns of
behavior or input or other things and as
soon as you start doing that then you
start having to worry about these things
run on distributed computing platforms
so tying banners I mean so now all of
these things are on slightly different
clocks why does that matter
well because now you've lost global
synchronization so suppose that what
happens is that one of your processors
sees something jump in front of you but
another processor that message hasn't
gotten to it yet does that matter what
happens if they happen in the other
order how do you make sure right that
somehow these things behave properly
when we've now got this complex event
system right with different
interleavings of events have
all the time hmm sure throw on top of
that that you know soon as people put
networking communications in they say
jeez why do I just have to communicate
with the computers inside my car inside
my airplane inside my building why don't
I communicate with the outside well
alright so now you start doing all right
cloud resources different operators
other subsystems we start
interconnecting all of this stuff
together so this is what a modern
control system looks like and this is
what we've got to go design to now it's
all just feedback loops and right you
know design of dynamics and you know
managing uncertainty right but it's
complicated so in some sense it's still
just sensing actuation and computation
in the old style of control but it very
much it's really about dynamics
uncertainty feed-forward and feedback
right so duff beer all the way across
all of these layers so you know the
field is exciting right now because
right we've got these really complicated
systems that we have to go implement and
I would say you know the systems we saw
yesterday you know are examples of that
right in some sense we're not necessary
it's not the only problem to solve the
feedback control problem right but
there's a feedback part of that problem
as well okay so you know lots of
examples of systems that look like this
so aerospace systems look like this
self-driving cars look like this factory
automation systems look at the smart
building smart grid smart transportation
systems look like this right I mean
these you know they have these multiple
layers they have all these things going
on at once they're distributed right all
of that stuff and so we have answers for
some pieces with you know other parts we
don't there are lots of interesting
challenges um certainly one is how do we
define the layers of this right so we
want to break our design apart in layers
right what is the inner loop what is the
trajectory generation loop what is this
discrete decision-making loop you know
you'll have discrete variables down at
this level so what the heck's going on
Raimi's just you know how do we break
apart the problem standard computer
science problem right you know you've
got them you want to make a multi-layer
hierarchy you know where do you put the
layers what are the interfaces between
the layers all of that stuff and so we
think about that for example as when I
create those layers I have to have an
understanding at this layer of the
design I want to treat the lower layers
as just simplified abstraction and so
I've got to have some contract that says
for example the online optimization is
going to assume that if I tell the lower
level feedback control to track this
trajectory within ten centimeter
that it's going to do that because now I
know that I will stay within 10
centimeters of whatever trajectory you
give me so I can use that for my
planning purposes because I need to know
that you might be up to 10 centimeters
on on the other hand that lower layer
has to say look I can't stay within 10
centimeters if you tell me you know to
turn you know sort of really sharply at
20 miles an hour and you want me to go
around in really shelter I can't do that
I mean just physically can't do that so
I have to assume that you're going to
give me all right
reasonable trajectories and under the
assumption that you give me reasonable
charities I'll guarantee I'll fall I'm
within 10 centimeters and then the other
part that's say okay fine if you
guarantee you follow them within 10
centimeters right I'll guarantee you so
I'll assume you're gonna follow them
within 10 centimeters I'll guarantee
that I give you reasonable trajectory so
you get a set of assumed guarantee
contracts between the layers we call
these vertical contracts so at every
layer but to actually need some vertical
contracts about what can I assume about
the layer above and a layer below and
what can I guarantee to those layers and
then those will turn into assumptions
for the other layers or at least my
assumptions should be bigger than the
set of guarantees right so then one fits
within the other so that's one way to do
it the other is that many of these
systems are distributed and so we have
horizontal contracts as well right I've
got a whole bunch of bikes out there a
whole bunch of cars out there hoping
right and they're all interacting with
each other
also within each layer of abstraction so
if we're doing platooning or something
like that somebody asked about that
right then of course you know the
controller's at that low level are all
interacting with the other to try and
maintain things and I better have a set
of contracts that say if you implement
these assumed guarantee conditions at
your layer of abstraction than when you
interconnect with other things in that
layer of abstraction you'll be okay so
we call those horizontal contracts so we
need vertical contracts meaning
horizontal contracts we also of course
have to remember to think about things
like stability robustness and a big one
for control systems that we typically
have not done is security and privacy so
Stuxnet was a SCADA loop right so skate
a supervisory control and data analysis
or whatever SCADA stands for right the
see I'm pretty sure is control all right
and so guess what you know I'm going to
assume that any command that comes
across my bus is valid okay mmm that's
not maybe not such a good assumption if
somebody put a USB key into a computer
someplace right so a lot of systems
right we've not thought about right how
do we guarantee that these are secure
and and especially as they become
networked interconnected right and
autonomous cars become networked
interconnected and they start speeding
information right we got it worrying
about that privacy the same they can
leak information that you don't want to
leak okay so these layered approaches
design I think are very interesting and
we're you know starting to think about
them and they enter in all of these
systems and again and each layer there
are these sorts of control problems
between the layers of the sorts of
control problems I'll just you know say
what I said before in terms of the way
we think about these at the physical
layer you might start with differential
equations and constraints on set and
you're thinking about things like how do
i optimize the operator operating on
below for the energy efficiency at the
regulatory layers you get these funky
formulas that the control engineers love
right that are telling you things about
transient and steady-state response at
the next layer of abstraction you're
probably solving some sort of an
optimization problem this optimization
problem here I've written as a sort of
deterministic optimization problem but
it might be unexpected values and
moments and other things that's all fine
you can do a stochastic version of all
of this and then at the highest layer
you probably have you know some sort of
finite state automaton and one of these
formulas that the computer scientists
can read but most the rest of us can't
write that is describing some sort of
other types of properties so let me just
say a little bit about I'm gonna kind of
talk a little bit about these two layers
because that's where our current work is
this is kind of a preview of some stuff
that I'll say on Tuesday all right so I
kind of want to focus on things that
these layers and the interactions
between users just to give you a sense
so let me first start by defining these
funky symbols so this is an area called
temporal logic there are lots of
different temporal logics out there the
one that we tend to use because it's
kind of the simplest and fairly common
is linear temporal logic so in linear
temporal logic we want to look at
sequences of events there's no explicit
notion of time there's just events that
occur and they're ordered and we want to
write down formulas about the events
that occur and so we define a couple of
operators the diamond means event
and that because something is eventually
true if at some point in the future that
property will become true you will be in
the correct lane you will stop will turn
laugh whatever the box means always that
means that should be true at all times
you will not run into other cars you
will always be at least one meter away
from other cars something like that you
will always use less than the power that
you have available and then there's some
other funky operators who want use and
so you can think of this as I got a
sequence of so if a is some proposition
and I've got a sequence of events sort
of written as if they were linear in
time you know it fixed time intervals
but these could occur with any amount of
time between them then whenever an event
occurs if I say eventually a I could
have that a is not true so not a not a
not a but at some point a must be true
and then this operator is true on a
sequence if a is true at one point and
after that I don't care
it's just eventually true once that's it
always of course means that a should be
true at all times and never not be true
and the interesting things come when you
start combining these so for example I
can say always eventually proposition P
is true that's a liveness condition I
mean always eventually checking your
left mirror always eventually make sure
your bike has a hundred percent of it
you know they're 95% of your bikes are
they're always eventually right you know
make sure some other property is true
that the room gets locked up I can also
do it the other way I can say eventually
always what does that mean that means
that at some point in the future it will
be true forever after that something is
true it is eventually always true that
you are in within ten centimeters of the
runway line that might be one that you
like I mean can you like the state
within ten centimeters of that runway
line not just get there once right you
know go skating across it right I want
to get there and stay there right so
it's like a stability property in some
sense and there are lots of other things
that you can do with these right so you
can say P applies eventually Q that's
like a response if P happens then
eventually Q must happen you know a
problem with all of this is that in
computer science these are events that
occur but there's no notion of timing
how long does it take so people have
started to extend it with things like
metric temporal logic we use something
called signal temporal logic and in
signal temporal logic you add some set
based things that aren't important but
you also add
tying bounds to things so you might say
that between time T 1 and T 2 P should
be true or P implies that eventually Q
is happened between time 0 and T so
within T seconds I get a response so
these sorts of temporal logics are
things that can be very important but so
we can now write down specifications in
this language so let me sort of skip
past this stuff so I won't do a really
simple example just because I want to
get to some of the other things but here
are some examples of those things now
one of the things we can do is think
about this now for the point of view of
a control system so suppose for example
I have this is my standard right
standard model for control except now my
process dynamics my environment dynamics
and my controller dynamics they're going
to be discrete state finite transition
systems and so finite state transition
systems so I'm gonna you know go from
state 1 to state 2 to state 5 to States
this which might be the number of parts
in the queue or right you know do I turn
left or right or right various things
where you have a discrete state it might
have a specification here I've written 1
don't worry about what it is a sort of
not written a good way I might have some
specification made out of temporal logic
and now I can say great I want to call
lqr all right give me I've given you a
specification minimize this cost
function I give you a description of the
system X dot equals ax plus B you find
the controller right well the equipment
B here I given you a finite state
transition system that describes the
dynamics I've given you a temporal logic
specification synthesize the reactive
controller if the environment does this
you do this if the environment does that
you do that so that would be the
equivalent of this so that's a great
problem to go solve this is a synthesis
problem there's only one problem with
that synthesis problem it's doubly
exponentially complex in the size of the
system specification so if I have five
specifications it takes me two to the
fifth that's 32 so 2 to the 32
nanoseconds to solve it and if I double
the number of specifications it takes me
2 to the 2 to the 10th that's 2 to the
1,000 that's the life of the universe in
nanoseconds right so it's like the worst
possible
so great problem to solve except it's
unsolvable right intractable I can't do
it for general specifications but cut a
neat thing happen which it turns out
there's a subset of controllers that
change a little bit what goes on
basically what we assume is that we can
measure what the environment is going to
do and react to it and the environment
is not allowed to change it's much like
a Stackelberg game if you do game three
types of things right but it's
essentially breaking the symmetry it's
not a complete game theoretic thing I
see what the environments gonna do ice
the monument commits to an action I see
what that action is going to be I can
respond to that if you do that then and
that's not too bad because you can say
well that's not fair right why should
you get to see what the environment but
you know I'm running in this iteration
right so I can say well you know I see
that the person starting to turn
as long as for the next hundredth of a
second I you know sort of assume they're
starting turn if they stop turning all
know that 100 seconds later I'll replan
so we kind of go into this receding
horizon framework right you can kind of
deal with this so if you assume that
then you can kind of unwrap this
execution right and say look the
environment choses in action I know what
the action is then the controller
chooses its action we implement the
action of the controller and the
environment on the process and we get a
new state and then the environment gets
to see that state it gets to choose an
action we go through this over and over
again and now you can imagine if we can
do that then I can kind of reason about
well what action do I have to take not
only to make sure that I keep the system
safe right now but that I eventually hit
my progress conditions and other things
so turns out for a certain class of
specifications and it's this class of
specifications it's the complexity of
the synthesis problem is cubic in the
number of states that way exponential
versus cubic and it just became a linear
program right I mean all of a sudden
right it's like whoa all right so a
couple of things this is the class of
specification it says that I have to
have a safety condition on the
environment and a progress condition on
the environment so the the environment
have to tell you here are things that
cannot do and here are things that will
always eventually do right so it'll
eventually get out of the way or it'll
eventually right do something and I want
that to imply that I will always be safe
and I will always make some progress
I'll always eventually make it through
the intersection I'll always eventually
recharge right you know but I have to
all
the environment has to always eventually
put power at the recharging station or
always eventually have a bike rack that
I can get into so you get this
environmental assumption implying a
system guarantee and it turns out that
for this if you can represent the okay
so here's where I'm lying so it turns
out representing this specification you
can represent it using a finite state
automaton called Ibuki atomic on and the
mapping from an arbitrary specification
even of this form to a buki automaton
could be exponential number of states in
the size of the specification but
typically not typically they're pretty
small so cubics still pretty good
because usually we get specs that can be
represented as relatively small numbers
of states and then we can solve these
problems okay so this is called gr 1
general reactivity it is an assumed
guarantee style specification like my
contracts I mean under the assumption of
the environment does this the system
will guarantee this so we can also use
this to synthesize things between the
layers right so notice the environment
might be the layer above me or the
environment might be the other players
in the game right so it fits in that
kind of a framework ok so just to kind
of show you a little bit about why you
know it makes sense that this might be
solvable I'm gonna give you a really
simple game and this is a game that
Pinelli did
I'm one of the pioneers in this field
and it's called the runner blocker game
and the idea is the following we've got
a runner our the runner can be in any
one of four states here here here or
here the runners goal is to get to this
state here there's a blocker the blocker
can be in any one of three states the
ones that are labeled red in the middle
at the top or the bottom
the blocker wins if the blocker is in
the same state is the runner the winner
the runner wins if it gets to the green
state G so the goal is eventually get to
G all right and never be in the same
state as the blocker ok so you can write
that down as a temporal logic
specification so how do we solve this
problem obviously very simple one and
you can probably see what the solutions
going to be so the first thing we do not
the way you would really do it but you
know for this example is we enumerate
all the possible system States so here's
the state we started in
alright here's the winning state down at
the bottom right where I'm on the right
hand side and every other possible
combination some of these are losing
States alright so first thing I can
write transitions between all these
right so here's I get from all of these
states to all these other states by
either the red ones are the environment
the block removes the blue ones are I
move and some of these are winning
states and some of them are losing
states so what do I want to do well I
want to get to this state suppose I
assume I start in that state then I win
now I can ask the question well what are
the set of states from which if the
environment chooses any action I can
choose a subsequent action that will get
me into the winning state well that's
this set of states so I remember I broke
it right so essentially what happens is
only one moves at a time and I know
right ahead of time what the walkers
going to do so another time the runner
you have to decide you're gonna move
left great I know you're gonna move up I
now get to decide you can't change your
mind you have to move left
so each you know sort of the red arrows
are there they don't happen at the same
time one happens than the other happens
now effectively I could think of these
two happening at the same time it
wouldn't change much but I think so if I
start in either one of these states then
of course it's pretty obvious right so
here I'm up here the blockers down here
right the blocker can only do one thing
if you move up here that's fine I'm
going to move here I'm gonna win now of
course it's the next layer so now I've
got a new set this is also a set of
winning states iterate so I'll use this
as a set of winning States what is the
set of states from which right if the
blocker takes any action that I can find
a counter action such that well that's
of course this top state that's the only
want to add and the idea here is that if
the blocker moves up right then what I'm
going to do is move down because now I
know I can win well I'm not going to do
is move the other way because then I
would lose
so what you do is you use a you want a
fixed point out of you let me say here's
the set of winning states that I know
now expand that to the set of states
from which I can choose an action so
that's they will now expand that keep
doing that until you run out of states
now ask the question is my initial set
in that winning set my initial
conditions my initial set of states if
so then there's a strategy by which a
reactive controller can always win the
game and what do you do right well if I
start in any set like r2 I need to
choose the action that gets me into r1
and once I'm in r1 I need to choose the
action and gets me in r0 that's my
strategy there may be more than one all
right so I can optimize over that or do
other things so that's the way you can
solve this problem
and it turns out that's a cubic
complexity problem in the number of
states right there good algorithms for
solving that problem okay so that's sort
of what that looks like okay
so I think I want to stop there because
we're basically out of time
and so let me just sort of summarize a
little bit right so what I've tried to
tell you a little bit about was a couple
of ideas coming from curl three and so
one is that feedback is a tool to
provide robustness to uncertainty I
don't know which way the blocker is
going to move so I have to measure what
happens right I don't know how many
people are in the room I don't know what
the road conditions are like whatever
the uncertainty is feedback is up tool
for doing that uncertainty can be noise
disturbances on model dynamics feedback
also helps us design the dynamics of the
system that's important in layering
because I want to know that the dynamics
of the system at that layer are
something simple right from the point of
view of the upper layer so I want to
design them right to be something simple
so they can reason about it and when you
combine these together that's what
allows us to use feedback often to get
modularity and hierarchy in these
systems control theory is something that
you know the tools were originally
designed for these lower level control
systems PID controllers and other things
but increasingly they're being applied
to these network systems with hybrid
dynamics mixtures of discrete and
continuous dynamics for example long
lines what I showed you
and there are a lot of interesting
challenges left to go I've given you a
blazingly fast introduction to all of
this of course but I will plug a book
that talks about this so with the
exception of the very last part every
figure you saw came from this book okay
this book is free so it's a free
download so you're welcome to go to FBS
book that or at feedback systems book
out org and you get a free download of
this book if you want the version that
doesn't have a lot of bugs and errors
etc go to the first edition there's a
second edition that's what's on the
homepage that's the one we're working on
so it's the latest one that's there
we're writing up some of the stuff I
talked about at the end right for the
newest edition of the book but we
haven't gotten there yet so but you're
welcome to take a look at that and
probably a better resource than that is
me and remember I'm here and I'm happy
to talk to you and I'm here you know
Tuesdays through Thursdays in most weeks
and so I'd be happy to you know hey with
this idea seems like this you know can
we talk more absolutely so with that I
will stop and thank you for your time
and attention so we have time for few
questions
usually what I've seen all this is that
you have a guarantee for safety or
something so it's a certain condition
right what for example I don't know the
blocker if it's called 50/50 up or down
so is it like they did some focus
generalization to do not telling what
the expectation of the best I can do
yeah so you can do a couple of things so
in the in the kind of version I gave you
I'm going to give you a bound on the
blockers behavior right it can only move
one square at a time for one motion at a
time all right things like that I'm
gonna give that to you as a finite state
machine or a temporal logic formula or
whatever and then I'm gonna solve the
worst case problem right no matter what
the blocker does it can be
non-deterministic it could do anyone
five things I want to reason about every
possible case people have also done
things where you say ah but what if it's
actually like a Markov chain right and
so with some probability it's going to
do this and this right and then I can
say first I could still say worst case
but I could also say well I'd like the
expected I'd like to win most of the
games yes that can be done and so there
are probabilistic versions of all of
this and you can do probabilistic
synthesis it tends to turn into a Markov
chain choose the parameters of a market
a decision process to get some
stationary distribution of the market of
the underlying Markov chain but there
are efficient algorithms for doing that
and people have layered on top of it
these sort of temporal logic formulas
which after all are formulas on paths
through the Markov chain right so you
say for example and always eventually in
a Markov chain often will be a cycle
right you're looking for a cycle that
goes through some states over and over
and over again right so now you're
looking for last so like not last so
like the optimization lasso but lasso
like it's got a you know sort of part a
finite part and then a cycle at the end
and you're searching over those things
for things that satisfy the right
probabilities so yeah you can do those
too
something it's maybe too big to be a
question that you have a process that
you view as a box with inputs and
outputs to be controlled but there there
are lots of systems in the world
especially social ones where that
process itself has feedback loops inside
it I think like a national economy right
very well want to control right but but
the process within the economy is in
some sense resisting control so is there
a theoretical basis for for dealing with
systems of that kind some so as you
already alluded to you know part of the
problem is that we have to reason about
these systems using some model of what
the behaviors are right and if those
models are not accurate for example if I
say well if I invest in this technology
right then Society will you know do this
the other but Society says you know the
hell I'm going to do that because I
don't want to that's not in my model now
I can go way wrong right because of
course I reasoned assuming one thing and
it turned out to be something different
and that's I think a big you know where
you see control systems being applied I
think quite successfully are in systems
where you have good underlying physics
based models for example right we're
pretty sure what we know of the laws of
physics for an airplane are or a room or
whatever there may be variables there
like how many people in the room is
Sitter but I can bound that right I can
say there's no more than you know
however many seats there are and there's
a certain number of BTUs per person and
so that's an upper bound on the amount
of heat look so those are the situations
where it works well what people are
trying to do for situations that you
can't model as well is use data-driven
models right so I'll just do
representation I'll give you an example
of one that kind of shows maybe what can
be done so and also some of the pitfalls
so we were trying to do some problems
where we were doing robot path planning
through a crowded cafeteria so the idea
is I want to go from here to the salad
bar but there's a bunch of people in the
way if you solve it as a standard robot
path planning problem you say well you
know what I'm going to do is I'm going
to predict where everybody's going to be
and I'm not going to move in
anyway that somebody might run into me
okay if you do that in a crowded
cafeteria you will stand there and never
move right because there's always people
cutting in front of you the whole point
is when you walk forward they're gonna
stop right but they're going to stop
until you walk forward right okay so
then what do you do right well okay so
you can model that because you can take
data right and watch what people do and
now I can do Bayesian inference
essentially right I can say well let me
you know sort of say if I move forward
what's the probability this person is
going to stop and if that probability is
greater than 99% I will treat that as a
useful action right so we did that and
indeed we were able to move through the
cafeteria right and we would do what you
would expect which is you walk in front
of somebody they slow down you keep
going right it all sort of works
beautifully until the people say oh
that's a robot all right I'm gonna stand
in front of it right you know it's like
you're trying to move by in and then
you're like standing in front of you and
they break up because they didn't do
that to other people it's not in your
data set right and so you know it's
exactly the same type of thing right all
of a sudden like people get these funny
feelings right people in autonomous cars
are worried about this right because you
know you're gonna say oh it's an
autonomous car just walk don't worry
about what the light says right it has
to stop all right well yeah but you know
the model that it used to figure out you
know what do probably didn't predict you
we're gonna walk right in front of a car
going 30 miles an hour I think I barely
stopped right now hitting a few
pedestrians is a way to change yes right
we will not will change the behavior on
the other side right right but you're
absolutely right so these are limited to
things where you have some ability if
you want the robustness and the way that
control theorists think about it you
need some ability to reason about the
bounds on behaviors and if you brake
outside of those bounds all your
guarantees go away yeah that's great
question
each using their own control citizen is
it a good idea or a bad idea of
standards and homogeneity of the control
or is it dangerous to have different
control so I guess one answer would be
that there need to be probably an
agreed-upon set of contracts which could
just be the rules of the road right you
will stay in your lane you will stop you
know when the light turns red and things
like that that facilitate that
interaction right and so they may not
need to coordinate or make use of
information from each other or have a
common system as long as they've got a
common specification right and and that
specification can allow me to implement
things differently than you do just like
people drive differently than others
that could be okay of course if
everybody implements things in exactly
the same way that could lead to a lot
you know better uniformity right maybe a
lot harder try to close it or my own
personal feeling is that you know the
difficulty with that is that those sorts
of things probably make sense when 100
percent of the cars are autonomous but
we're not there and I can't tell you how
to drive right um you can drive like
you're gonna drive and so we probably
have to solve the problem of other
agents that you're interacting with not
following the same even rules that
you're following let alone implementing
the same way so we probably have to
solve the problem but yeah if you can so
now give you a different example people
who know Amazon bought Kiva systems Kiva
systems does these warehousing robots
right they all behave by exactly the
same rules right so you know exactly
what's going on you can replace anyone
with any other one right you can reason
about them because you know exactly what
they're going to do and they all
implement the same controllers that's a
good thing right but they're in a very
controlled environment but it probably
would make the problem easier because
everything would be kind of symmetric
but I don't know that we can I don't
know how to get from here to there all
right except in these you know very
controlled environments like a warehouse
where you're going to control everything
yeah so the other one you would worry
about too and just say the aircraft
control industry worries about this a
lot not so much because of adversarial
stuff but one of the things that worried
about a lot was you know you typically
in an aircraft
depending on how safety credit goes you
have two or three processors doing your
flight controls and they'll vote they
use a you know the Byzantine consensus
algorithm typically to make sure that
right you know sort of if a controller
fails right that the right thing happens
but the other thing they worry about is
common mode failure right so there's a
bug and it's the same algorithm running
on each one and so the same bug right
they all interpret the signal
differently so the way they handle that
often these days I mean now they're
getting a little bit more less paranoid
about it but in the old days they would
have different teams design each
controller in different programming
languages implemented on different micro
processors all right to make sure right
you know that if the Intel
floating-point failure or whatever was
in one of them right it wasn't gonna be
in the other two all right and so that's
what they would do and that of course
could also give you something work for
adversarial attack right you know
there's the attack vector is you know
I'm gonna hit you know some number of
your processors or not all of them so
there's another one where you might
worry about if everything did it the
same way and a virus spread through
writing your entire traffic system
Falmer absolutely
so how do we deal with the time sink
problem and distributed and dynamic
systems where all those things are
actually moving so they have to
incorporate the changes in their
internal clocks and to their internal
clocks at a given moment yeah so a
starting point for that is to so
computer scientists have also thought
about this and you can think about
banking transaction systems distributed
things like Bitcoin and other things and
so there are consensus algorithms by
which we can all guarantee that we
reason about things in the same order
right so you use logical clocks and
vector clocks for people who are
computer scientists the problem with
those things are that they are not fast
so they're not designed to implement be
implemented in real time particularly
and so but you can do things where you
say so now I think the way people would
deal with is they say well we allow some
amount of clock skew but we control very
carefully the clock skew and then we
have to prove right that if I've got 10
processors and they could each have a
millisecond clock skew in any direction
that this algorithm will always do the
right thing independent of the
interleaving with all of those so that's
now a verification problem right where
you worry about doing verification over
interleaving executions and some of that
can be solved via verification but
usually in a I guess I would might and
are not super expert in this but usually
in a very specific case if I tell you
there are 10 processors and here's the
amount of effort said I can do it if I
tell you well I don't know how many cars
are gonna be on the road right they're
all gonna have slightly different clocks
and they're all gonna see the red light
turn in a slightly different time right
and I need to reason about that
generally I don't know how to do that
problem yet so there's starting points
but now it's not solved how much do you
spend on ensuring the clock sink and
essentially establish consensus and how
well does your environment this cited
section doesn't change my approximation
work in the system yeah so if you can do
something where you can just make it for
example a kind of you know time shift
invariant right that's the ideal thing
or it doesn't actually matter right that
the clocks are off right and so then I
don't spend any time doing consensus
right I think most the time you can't do
that and so now what you said is a great
trade-off right so like how much so
somebody asked me this question during
the breaks you know time delay is one of
the things that works very badly with
feedback control systems right because
if I tell you to do something and
there's a long delay between when you do
it and there's another long delay
between when what you did in what I see
actually happens right I can get out of
sync right and so you see this like in
your shower sometimes right you know you
sort of turn the shower to harder
doesn't get hotter so you turn it up
more right and it gets too hot right you
know because there was a delay right so
you turn it way down right it takes you
a while to settle in right so those
delays are a problem consensus
algorithms could have delays and so that
would be a trade-off right I want to do
it fast but maybe I can't do it that
well it's a good question I don't know
I'd love to talk more about it you know
maybe there's a nice mathematical
formulation in there that can be put
together there are class of systems for
which the complexity is big but from
what you described what about how one
would actually go about it seems like
either one would be one would be solving
the fix problems or one will be
enumerated so I don't understand so both
of them seems you know they're very
intractable problems we have exponential
complexity so yeah so the way you solve
it is that you represent your formulas
as BD DS binary decision diagrams and
then you do reasoning at the level of BD
DS and so I give you a BDD that scrapes
a winning set and then I compute out a
BDD describes the next bigger one and it
turns out you can for gr1 specifications
you can encode those efficiently and
that's what they're able to show is
essentially a kind of cubic calculation
and well I think it's cubic in the basic
algorithm and then implementing and BD
DS allows you to solve very large
problems so we typically serve solve
things that might have 10 to the 9th
states or something like that right so
you know billions of discrete States
between the specification and the
control system and and you know they're
the algorithms for doing it are not
particularly complicated you know maybe
a dozen lines of Python code you know
sitting on top of a BDD library that's
implementing everything so I'm happy you
know there's a program called Omega that
does this in Python for example it's
also and there's a BDD library that it
sits on top of called DD
yeah but it works very practical problem
so the answer could be just go read
water magazine oh yeah over the last ten
years we've gone with respect to UAVs
and copters in particular from academic
somersaults to to stuff that's on the
Shelf of fries right would you how would
you care were there any advances in the
control aspect that made that possible
or is it just an batteries got low
enough so there's enough power to give a
couple of minutes no I mean a lot of
technologies all at once of course rain
control was one of those so you know one
of the things that makes you know
quadrotors work is that you know more or
less you say hover and it just hovers at
Holt's right I mean they're really good
controllers right so why does that work
well that works because they have pretty
accurate gyros and accelerometers right
and so that's the technology of your
cell phone is driving all right because
they're getting better and better and
better right like the shakealert
extensors they have lots of computations
so what you want to do is you want to
compute very quickly right because you
want if you want to be rock-solid you
want if it's off by you know a micro
Radian right that you correct a little
bit right that means that you know as
this thing's moving around you need to
be computing fast enough to see that
that's another you know the the reason
the control systems work so well is
because we can put you know pretty fast
computation on those with really good
sensors that are very accurate have low
noise and all of that just comes
together and the motors can react fast
enough right so that you know these
little tiny motors that people have been
making now they you know optimize them
and other things so I wrote a robotics
book way back and one of my co-authors
was a shingly
say shang lee's master's student is
frank when frank Wayne is the CEO of DJI
right and so if you go talk to them
right you know this is what they say it
basically will tell you what's driving
DJI is they use cell phone components
for almost everything except the motors
right and they wind their own motors
right they make their own motors so they
can get the performance that they need
but all of the computing all of the you
know sort of communications all of the
gyros and other things all of the
cameras etc all of that is going forward
because of cell phone technology and
that's just making it cheaper higher
performance right letting you put more
things on there
so the motors are now good enough right
for these small things it helps to get
them smaller because big motors are hard
to get to move faster so that's nothing
a lot of what's driving it maybe you
know I think a land vehicle side you
know honestly the hardest part of that
problem is driving in environments with
humans because you have to reason about
what the humans are going to do so you
know if you just want to drive and you
know how if you won't look at these
autonomous cars driving they're very
smooth they're very fast reacting there
is good probably as a human in terms of
just maneuverability and other things
the challenge that they have is they
come up to some weird stoplight
situation they've never seen before
right because you know some of there's a
flashing light some weird spot that gets
them confused etcetera right and what
there's a person who's you know looking
at their cell phone and walking in front
or something like that
I mean that's where the I think the hard
parts of the problem are the control
that's a control problem right it's just
a higher level right the lower level
control parts of the problem where you
would say the pace of Technology server
no only the one sensor one that's there
is we don't yet have truly cheap ways of
detecting within say a hundred meters of
a vehicle 250 meters of a vehicle what's
going on at the right resolution right
now everybody's using like these valid
ein laser rangefinder units there are a
hundred thousand dollars it's more than
the cost of most people's cars right and
so that's a problem but everybody is
sort of saying yeah but we believe
that'll be solved people gonna come out
with solid state light hours and right
you know sort of solve that problem so
we're gonna buy those things for our
test vehicles right spend a bunch of
money and then when that solution comes
along not well maybe from cellphone
technology I don't know right yeah the
iPhone 10 right has this you know face
scanner thing right you know that's some
sort of a proximity sensor in some sense
okay I guess let's time to say thank you
everybody
leave next day I'm sorry we'll meet
tomorrow